bonjour vous arrivé juste à temps je lui
comment sa chanson alors suivez-moi
suivez-moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avec beaucoup de couleurs
avec beaucoup de douceur
je voudrais faire
le tri
non
j'y vois les garçons
casimir show de sa chanson
françois
nouveau jeu
ah ah
mais je n'aurai mieux pas si j'avais eu
la faune
mais j'aimerais mieux pas si j'étais un
enfant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je
[Musique]
saha
non
alors le client
les poupées
on les aime
épaulé
couleur cerise c'est tout
crozon
non
[Musique]
à papillons passe en temps
assis sur un banc
[Musique]
utile m
mais je m'en fais mieux ta si je taisais
la fin
mais je leur ai
si j'étais à londres
[Musique]
là
[Applaudissements]
ah
bravo julie mabhouh
j'adore ta chanson
est très belle mais malgré tout il ya
quelque chose dans le texte qui ne me
plaît pas beaucoup
viens tu sais au moment où quichotte
mais je l'aurais mieux pas si j'étais un
enfant il vaudrait beaucoup mieux que tu
chantes mais je l'aurais mieux pas si
j'étais un casimir us à
casimir je crois que tu n'as pas tout à
fait raison et je vais pouvoir tant
donné la preuve est-ce que tout à
l'heure françois va m'apporter des
dessins d'enfants bon et bien puisque
c'est ainsi je vais chez moi chercher
tous les dessins de casimir eu ce projet
d'accord rapidement pourquoi
françois vient d'apporter les dessins
d'enfants attendent de moi j'en ris
maintenant
de recevoir ses dessins commencez votre
cet affreux casimir je t'en prie coûte
bon vous en pensez de
tout regarder la légende casimir la
coqueluche des enfants parce que c'est
là que tu lui as
dit plus tôt oui mais quand je m'en fous
gars c'est autre chose a conclu c'est à
dire c'est le héros l'idole des enfants
bien que tout rosati casimir celui ci
est encore quasi mais il y en a que pour
toi y côtoie du critique en parallèle il
est beau en suisse un nazi l'arbre est
très beau il manque un peu tâche à
casimir cantons tels que sascha quasi
mêleront de t'être et vous avez vu
comment réinvestir bon voire très bon
ensuite
après
l'annoncé par rapport à kazimiyah
effectivement casimir et est beaucoup
trop long
mais casimir arrêté un petit peu vous
allez les enfants on peut interpréter et
on n'est pas obligé de faire exactement
ce qu'on va là je pense que le petit
garçon est critique et à interpréter
voilà alors là il ya un petit peu tout
le monde
françois casimir juni qu'est ce qu'ils
en pensent et de se changer d'air dans
le groupe 1 millions dont je parle dans
ma chanson regardent ils s'envolent mais
cette fois depuis qu est-ce qui sera
quand il me lâche
et la forme et la couleur de casino
qui a raison celui-ci vraiment moche à
lui si
vraiment ces cinq ans et ses fils marc
et cinq ans et demi
voilà les je suis pas d'accord les
étagères sont un petit peu vide salut
vous pensez que c'est julie
jeune femme ne peut plus durer des mois
je vais vous montrer à un trait pour des
siens regarder voilà voilà regarder ça
au moins c'est du dessin
tu entends les réponses des enfants pas
de toute façon en question peinture
chacun peut avoir son goût en france les
gazinières tu étais tellement méchant
tout à l'heure en faisant des remarques
désobligeantes sur tous les dessins des
enfants que moi je ne vais pas te dire
que je trouve cette peinture très laide
alors
[Musique]
c'est incroyable d'avoir aussi mauvais
goût oui à tout il manque peut-être la
mer dans le fond
les ballons de france va sa chaise
je suis vraiment un incompris sur cette
île
mais ça ne se passera pas comme ça un
nom ils se souviendront de moi cher
françois scheer julie je pense que c'est
la dernière fois que vous entendrez
parler moore je m'en vais je quitte
lille aux enfants pour chercher un pays
mon talent de peintre sera enfin après
si je ne vous en veux pas mais je ne
fais plus supporté qu'on se moque de moi
j'espère que vous garderez un bon
souvenir de moi je pars à l'aventuré la
vie sera dur mais je préfère mourir de
faim et de soif dans un désert plein de
serpents plutôt que d'être considéré
comme un imbécile avons jamais considéré
comme un imbécile pour surnom à dieu
dont ne m'oubliez pas casimir mais c'est
terrible n'est plus jamais voir qu'ils
imitent ils sont faire quelque chose il
vous manque tout ça en fait tort tenez
s'il arrive à maintenant je lui donnerai
tous les jouets mon coeur mon petit
cochon rose on hippopotames rouge la
tortue et puis tout mais dragées au
poivre
ou de joie quand je préfère et me
tracteur je serai prêt à regarder la la
collection complète de ses tableaux un
joli un renfort cabinet
du grand est pour toujours les égéries
contre moi aussi je suis content de vous
revoir tenez j'ai pensé à tout j'ai même
apporté une valise pour mettre tous les
jouets que julie doit me donner et pour
toi françois jetté apporter ma
collection complète de dessin
voit la case
vous aimez avoir à faire